a lighter ps5 has quietly hit the
shelves and sony is buying another
studio
new ps5 models have launched in
australia and similar to previous
playstation iterations of the past they
bear new model numbers these new
additions don't have any cosmetic
changes but they are lighter than
previous belts as spotted by press start
the disc ps5 has shed another 300 grams
or 0.66 pounds and now weighs 3.9
kilograms or 8.5 pounds
while the digital ps5 is 200 grams or
0.44 pounds lighter and it tilts the
scale at 3.4 kilograms or 7.4 pounds and
this isn't the first time that sony has
trimmed down the ps5 either as a
previous revision saw its heatsink
swapped out for a slimmer version in
total the disk ps5 is now 600 grams or
1.3 pounds lighter than the original
model while the digital ps5 has lost 500
grams or 1.1 pounds overall but the ps5
isn't the only thing losing weight
because if you live in one of several
countries where the ps5 recently got a
price increase
your bank or your wallet might also be
shedding some pounds sony blames global
economic challenges and adverse currency
trends for the retail price increase in
europe the united kingdom the middle
east africa asia and parts of north
america although the u.s price has been
spared in response to this move by sony
nintendo announced that switch prices
would remain the same despite growing
production costs and microsoft also
confirmed that no xbox series x and s
price increase is currently in the cards
and in other playstation news they're
buying another studio today sony
interactive entertainment announced
plans to buy savage game studios a
mobile studio based in finland and
germany that is currently working on a
triple a live service game for mobile
whether or not this game will be a
playstation franchise or a new ip
remains to be seen savage will be folded
into sony's newly established
playstation studios mobile division
which handles mobile games and is
separate from its console team sony said
that its playstation team is trying to
meet gamers wherever they are and give
them whatever they want that could be a
mobile game a pc title or a live service
project sony also stressed that it will
continue to make unparalleled
single-player narrative-driven aaa
console games and while we're on the
subject of mobile games don't forget
we're hosting our first ever mobile show
called swipe on september 8th at 10 a.m
pacific 1 p.m eastern the showcase will
feature a wide variety of games from
different genres and you can expect
exclusive trailers and gameplay videos
game reveals and new details on upcoming
live service game updates some of the
major publishers and developers
confirmed for the show include
activision apple arcade ea netflix
ubisoft and more and now i need you to
hit the comment section and let me know
your favorite mobile game and don't you
dare say mobile sucks because i bet
you're watching this video on your phone
right now
i'll see you tomorrow